revenons maintenant sur le déraillement
survenu ce week-end dans le quartier
saint henri les conséquences sont
minimes mais l'incident soulève quand
même pas mal de questions jean-sébastien
j'ai fait récemment un dossier complet
sur la sécurité ferroviaire dans la
grande région de montréal
d'abord rappeler nos ce qui s'est passé
en fin de semaine ça s'est passé dans la
nuit de samedi à dimanche autour de
minuit on est ici le long d'une des
voies ferrées les plus achalandées au
pays les voies du cn rue de courcelles
pour vous situer un peu c'est entre
l'échangeur turcot et le marché atwater
donc autour de minuit deux trains se
croisent un des deux trains auraient dû
freiner attendre complètement que
l'autre bien sûr me soit parti avant
d'embarquer sur la même voie ferrée or
pour une raison qu'on ignore encore
l'enquète nous le dira il n'a pas freiné
à temps si bien que deux locomotive et
deux wagons sont allé heurter deux côtés
l'autre train les wagons n'ont pas versé
mais bien sûr on déraille et c'était des
wagons de serial mais avec l'impact bay
à un réservoir d'une des locomotives qui
a été percé et 3800 litres c'est pas
rien 3800 litres de diesel ont été
répandues au moment où on se parle
patrice derrière moi on est en train de
terminer la décontamination
heureusement le sol est gelé alors ça
facilite les choses pas de cours d'eau
autour pas canalisations non plus les
trains vont quand même lentement au
centre de mots à une trentaine de
kilomètres heure seulement mais quand
même les élus de montréal sont en droit
de se poser des questions aujourd'hui il
ya des résidences tout à côté
juste à côté une école également alors
je le sais que tu es benoit dorais le
maire de l'arrondissement du sud-ouest
qui dit lui qu'il a été avisé par le cn
à 10 heures le lendemain matin seulement
suivi d'anie samson responsable de la
sécurité publique à montréal qui l est
moins sévère envers la compagnie hier on
l'a vu c'était pas optimale et le cn
doit absolument mettre en place les
mécanismes de communication avec la
ville de montréal le service de police
la sécurité incendie et les
arrondissements les citoyens demandent
des informations sont inquiets on est
capable de les livrer je peux vous dire
que
l'événement ont eu des contacts avec le
cn on en eut façon constante ce qui
s'est jamais vu par le passé par les
administrations faut le dire là on était
be ce lien là est-ce que c'est parfait
peut-être parce qu'aucune ligne aurait
certainement lac long avec l'événement
qui vient d'arriver
ça va nous permettre de travailler sur
les failles mais jean-sébastien ce qu'on
a appris de mégantic autrement dit
est-ce que la collaboration de la vie
lycéenne a vraiment été meilleur oui
tout à l'heure madame samson nous dit qu
au moment où on se parle le sienne et la
ville sont en train de cartographier les
voies ferrées du cn et le sienne dit à
la ville et va dire à la ville qu'elle
produit dangereux parce ou alors ça va
aider beaucoup sur une grosse
amélioration il y aura aussi la
formation faite aux pompiers de montréal
pour mieux intervenir en cas de
déversement de matières dangereuses mais
voilà merci jean sébastien au revoir
avant